moins noir que prévu la journée des
grands départs et retours sur les routes
tout de même 650 km de bouchons à la
mi-journée mais pas d'accident justin
long flot ininterrompu de voitures
josé bové retourne chez lui au larzac il
est sorti de prison la mi-journée il
reprendra le combat ses premiers
rendez-vous si l'autorisation lui en est
donnée au mexique en septembre en corse
le rendez-vous des nationalistes après
le non au référendum la reprise des
attentats et l'arrestation d' yvan
colonna le chef de file jean guy
talamoni rejette la faute sur le
gouvernement
le festival interceltique à lorient
toutes les musiques celtes à l'honneur
pendant une dizaine de jours un rendez
vous incontournable pour les passionnés
et les curieux
madame monsieur bonsoir pour ce grand
chassé croisé de l'été les
embouteillages sous la chaleur ont
accompagné les automobilistes sur la
route des vacances
pas de record tout de même plus de 650
km de bouchons avec des pics d
encombrements essentiellement dans la
vallée du rhône pour ce samedi classé
noir un flot de voitures descendant vers
le sud alors qu en sens inverse
comment c'est le retour des juilletistes
virginie du mortier qui tire ici monnaie
un ticket pour l'enfer pour les matinaux
à 7 heures du matin déjà 150 km de
perturbations dans le sens du départ de
lyon à valence trois heures de route
c'est trois fois plus qu'en temps normal
c'est long très long
je pense que et ça va encore être pire
210 km de ralentissements peu avant midi
pare-choc contre pare-choc les
automobilistes s'échauffent au dessus de
leur tête la gendarmerie surveillent le
réseau pour éviter les catastrophes
la mission de l'hélicoptère elle est
multiple aujourd'hui c'est surtout la
surveillance du réseau
le renseignement ensuite dans un second
temps la liaison au sol avec des
patrouilles qu'on a soit à pied
celle qui surveille
les aires de repos soit les patrouille
motocycliste qui est le patrouille au
milieu de la circulation
monsieur s'il vous plaît la petite je ne
veux pas la voir assis sur la portière
et le petit garçon qui est là je veux le
voir derrière la surveillance est
difficile mais nécessaire les aires de
repos sont surchargées dans le sens du
départ avec la fatigue
les gens ont tendance à être moins
vigilant c'est ici que les problèmes
commencent
et en plus il fait 34 de flachau
répression
fait du bien de se rapprocher voire le
nord un trafic chargé et moi qu'est ce
qu'on attendait pour ces retours de
l'autre côté de l'autoroute
c'est un autre monde aucune grosse
difficulté de circulation pas de bouchon
sur les aires de repos
du coup les gens sont détendus ils
rentrent chez eux tranquillement encore
tout imprégné des réflexes de vacances
en région parisienne les automobilistes
ont commencé dès l'aube à prendre la
route très gros embouteillages sortir de
la capitale
les vacanciers en direction de la côte
atlantique où partant vers l'espagne se
sont armés de patience et une en fallait
de la patience pour traverser sous la
canicule une partie du pays tour
d'horizon avec frédéric monté sur
l'autoroute a8 le péage de la barque est
littéralement pris d'assaut par les
automobilistes ailleurs bison futé avait
vu noire pour les départs et rouge pour
les retours
autrement dit la galère pour tous et il
ne s'est pas trompé si ce soir la
circulation est à nouveau fluide
en revanche dès l'aube ça coinçait on
est parti à 4 heures et pour essayer
d'éviter mais apparemment
dû beaucoup de monde qui a eu le même
réflexe le même réflexe la même envie de
partir au soleil ou de revenir chez soi
du coup au plus fort des embouteillages
on a compté à midi et nuit jusqu'à 700 3
km de bouchon le record de l'an dernier
n'est pas tombé
a bordeaux beaucoup de bouche ont
également encore 6 km de ralentissements
en fin d'après-midi et beaucoup
d'automobilistes prudent avide de
petites pauses une pause papa bébés
toute la famille on est passionné par ce
matin on en a bien besoin
voilà on est content on est en vacances
cela dit mon bien et puis le
chassé-croisé juillettistes et aoûtiens
attirent toujours son lot d'excentrique
cet homme passe son temps à observer les
plaques d'immatriculation par curiosité
suite pour nora de mort et les dépens de
la france pour la tendance un petit peu
a oublié alors on sort je me remémore
les départements avec mon petit mon
petit parvient à nancy sur l'autoroute
a31 trente mille véhicules de plus
aujourd'hui l'occasion de renforcer la
surveillance policière en avion en
hélicoptère ou tout simplement sur terre
résultat ces motards néerlandais qui
zigzaguait ont été arrêtés il avait
pourtant plié leurs plaques
peine perdue en cette période de grands
départs les automobilistes peuvent
compter sur la vigilance des
patrouilleurs ses anges gardiens des
autoroutes dont ils assurent la sécurité
ils interviennent notamment en cas
d'accident pour baliser les lieux afin
d'éviter les carambolages portrait de
l'un d'entre eux sur l'a6 françois
jullien pieds-noirs valérie lucas
accident en paris lyon un paris lyon à
peine une heure de service les lieux et
déjà un accident au volant est l'un des
premiers avertis il doit se rendre le
plus rapidement sur les lieux
le patrouilleur est le premier sur les
accidents
effet la protection de l'accident mais
notice pas aux blessés un tête-à-queue
et la voiture sort de la route
roland doit sécuriser le secteur pour
éviter le sur accident
il faut ensuite tenir le gestionnaire
d'autoroutes au courant alors les seuls
véhicules en cause
oui oui deux blessés légers un avec 400
accidents par an sur le réseau le
patrouilleur facilite le travail des
autres acteurs de l'autoroute se mettre
en sécurité dans le derrière nous ils
nous permettent de travailler aisément
pour faire les constatations la
patrouille reprend et malgré les départs
en vacances c'est une journée comme les
autres pour roland les jours de grands
départs vote
normalement les véhicules roulent pro
très vite parce que trafic très chargé
et roland 90 et 110 km aujourd'hui 80
mille véhicules ont emprunté son réseau
mais rien à ramasser sur la voie et
pourtant on croise aussi bien du l'âge
des planches à voile des tables de
camping la bande d'arrêt d'urgence c'est
son domaine réservé mais roland ne s'y
attarde pas des amis patrouilleurs qui
ont déjà laissé leur vie région
parisienne l'envolée du mercure à
provoquer des pics de pollution
atteignant un niveau à cet après-midi
désir des consignes avaient été données
pour réduire la vitesse de 20km mêmes
recommandations pour demain son comité
d'accueil l'attendait à villeneuve les
maguelone josé bové sortie de prison en
début d'après midi le porte parole de la
confédération paysanne après six
semaines d'incarcération retrouvent la
liberté il finira sa peine tout près de
chez lui un travail à mi temps qui lui
laissera l'occasion de reprendre ses
activités syndicales il est d'ailleurs
décider si l'autorisation lui est donnée
de se rendre au mexique pour le prochain
sommet de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce sur place france envoie didier
leduc 14
un josé bové un peu amaigri et très émue
passe la porte de la maison d'arrêt sur
le seuil
sa compagne ses avocats et ses plus
proches amis de la confédération
paysanne 500 sympathisants et militants
sont venus l'accueillir
bové dehors c'est la fête et la cohue
depuis six semaines certains sont venus
manifester leur soutien tous les soirs
les premiers mots du leader syndical
sont donc pour une équipe absolument
ideye l'enceinte de la prison en prison
josé bové n'a voulu bénéficié d'aucun
traitement particulier et au
rez-de-chaussée parmi les autres détenus
j'étais dans une cellule qui donnait
comme ça a été expliqué
face à un mur pour être sûr d'une puisse
être en contact avec personne et surtout
pas avec l'extérieur
je passais 22 heures sur 24 dans cette
cellule
j'étais donc traités de la même manière
surpopulation et manque d'hygiène les
conditions de détention josé bové entend
désormais d inclure dans son combat
syndical à partir de lundi 9h la pâle
une association d'aménagement du larzac
emploiera josé bové à mi temps jusqu'à
la fin de sa peine en décembre avant
d'être incarcéré on va y est beaucoup
moins parce qu'elle a des
responsabilités syndicales très
importante
et là on va de l'avant de la nounou
presse ça c'est quand même viande 16h le
tam-tam quotidien de solidarité avec les
détenus
mais bové cette fois et à l'extérieur de
la prison il sera donc présent dans une
semaine au grand rassemblement sur le
plateau du larzac et au sommet de cancun
en septembre aussi comme porte parole de
ceux restés à l'intérieur
après le décès de marie trintignant la
fera la france espère l'extradition du
chanteur bertrand cantat compagnon de la
victime qui serait à l'origine du drame
hier à l autopsie de la comédienne on en
sait davantage sur les causes de sa mort
et les enquêteurs commencent à
recueillir des témoignages essentiels
pour retracer les heures qui ont précédé
la tragédie dorothée cochard hôpital de
la prison de vilnius
bertrand cantat y est toujours enfermé
il ne sait même pas que marie
trintignant est morte
nous avons pu joindre par téléphone son
avocat lituaniens qui lui a rendu visite
hier sur les circonstances qui ont
poussé au drame le chanteur maintient sa
version des faits accident ces accidents
le conflit verbal le conflit verbal au
coeur de la dispute cet homme le metteur
en scène samuel benchetrit l'ancien
compagnon de marie trintignant à qui
l'actrice était encore marié le soir du
drame l'homme aurait envoyé un message
affectueux à l'actrice et c'est ce qui
aurait été à l'origine de la dispute
entre les deux amants apparemment cantat
ne supportait pas qu'elle ait pu
conserver des liens fussent
professionnels susceptibles peut-être de
redevenir des liens affectifs à ses yeux
à lui pas aux yeux de marie trintignant
et donc sa colère s'est nourri de ça la
suite on ne la connaît que partiellement
la dispute s'envenime bertrand cantat
lève la main sur l'actrice une simple
gifle dira-t-il lors de l'audition du
juge en lituanie une déclaration que
viennent contredire les conclusions de
l'autopsié
elle aurait reçu non pas un mais
plusieurs coups très violents à
l'origine du décès cet après midi à
paris au quai des orfèvres
la police a interrogé nadine trintignant
la mère de l'actrice et vincent
trintignant son frère il était premier
assistant sur son dernier tournage c'est
lui que bertrand cantat a appelé à
l'aube
c'est lui qui s'est rendu compte de
l'état critique de l'actrice et c'est
lui qui appelait les gagner secours en
haute corse
un incendie s'est déclaré cet après midi
près de bastia 150 hectares de pinède
léchées par les flammes dans une zone
inhabitée
les canadairs sont entrés en action
ailleurs sur le continent alors que le
vent est tombé que les 1/100 dix ans
sous contrôle
les pilotes de la sécurité civile de
marignane critique le manque de moyens
aériens mis à leur disposition
la sécheresse de ces derniers mois
annonçait une saison à haut risque il a
fallu vous le savez faire appel à des
renforts venus d'étrangers d'ailleurs de
gros hélicoptères russes sont arrivés
aujourd'hui en france au kazoo amaury
guibert alexandre des kits il était
attendu c'est énorme hélicoptère russe
capable de larguer 20 tonnes d'eau sur
les incendies des renforts apprécié en
ce moment alors que les machines ont
beaucoup travaillé sur la base de
marignane
les pilotes ont déjà volé près de 4000
heures c'est trois fois plus que la
saison dernière mais il s'efforce de
rester philosophe on n'est pas en panne
mais on fatigue un peu mais problème
particulièrement sollicité les pilotes
de traqueur ses avions souvent dans
l'ombre des canadairs et qui joue
pourtant un rôle essentiel tous les
jours les pilotes prépare la même
mission de prévention dans notre région
à surveiller cette région si on a ici et
on à la région des pyrénées qui ouvre du
crime pas mal donc il faut qu'il y ait
en permanence au moins deux tracker
envol dans chaque région pour pouvoir
intervenir tout de suite son départ de
feu avant de s'envoler les appareils
font un détour au stand chargement
indispensable ce produit rouge c'est du
retardant en vol les pilotes scrutent
tous les départs de feu et l'arc ce
liquide ignifuges ans au sol voici le
résultat une partie calciné les traces
rouges du retardant et derrière la
végétation préserver ma femme est ce
qu'on appelle une barrière d'appui
rotterdam n'aucun du produit rouge qui
vient se mélangent et se met sur la
végétation ce qui permet de ralentir la
progression du feu lorsqu'ils arrivent
en contact ça ne stoppe pas et ça permet
de ralentir suffisamment pour que nous
au sol puisse intervenir qu on puisse
l'arrêter et les traqueurs avec l'aide
du retardant permettent de maîtriser les
deux tiers
des feux de forêt l'absence de politique
de prévention a été souligné ces
derniers jours notamment dans le var où
la ministre de l'ecologie roselyne
bachelot affirmait qu'aucune commune
n'avait entrepris de mettre en place des
dispositifs limitant la construction
dans des zones à risques d'incendié
reste que ces mesures sont extrêmement
coûteuses donc hors de portée car une
gautier romain pitau qui les massifs du
var n'avait pas souffert ainsi depuis
1990 à l'époque il est question de
politique de prévention
aujourd'hui il faut en évoquer les
lacunes l'occasion pour roselyne
bachelot ministre de l'écologie de
remettre en selle les plans de
prévention des risques datant de 1995
à ce jour le var ne possède aucun et
pour cause qui dit plan dit contrainte
et un coût élevé
les plantes sont rien n'a pas les dents
il n'y a pas les moyens qui vont avec
effectivement pas lié par exemple les
broussailles mans le long des chemins
des warri
je sais pas la commune du
plan-de-la-tour la commune la garde
freinet 80 kilomètres de wavrin
impossible effectivement d'assurer
effectivement le débroussaillement
convenable de part et d'autre s'il n'ya
pas effectivement une aide c'est
broussailles en bordure de chemin
représente un risque pour les incendies
ces maisons construites en plein coeur
des pinèdes en illustre un autre pas de
démolition possible alors leurs
propriétaires sont tenus de
débroussailler mais beaucoup rechignent
faute de moyens dit style rares sont les
familles qui comme celle de cet
agriculteur assument pleinement leur
choix de vivre dans une zone à risque
c'est que quand on habite dans le coin
isolé c'est un choix c'est un choix de
vie
c'est un choix de pays aussi et donc
depuis toujours dans cette équipe et de
façon à être autonome vous avez ici
exactement ce que le matériel dans le
social tombe bien c'est combien de
mètres avec des rallonges encore met
bout à bout la violence des feux de
juillet suffira-t-elle à réveiller une
fois pour toutes les pouvoirs publics la
prévention exige de la persévérance et
selon les maires des communes sinistrées
elle a jusqu'ici souvent fait défaut en
europe la canicule atteint des sommets
plus de 50 degrés assez vide de
personnes en sont mortes dans le sud du
pays
sur le front des incendies des feux de
forêt ont léché des zones résident
ciel non loin de madrid quant au
portugal attisés par des vents violents
les flammes poursuivre leur progression
le point ces noces eau des villes a
attaqué par les flammes
plus de 1500 maisons ont été évacuées
cette nuit en toute hâte à l'est de
madrid au moins deux mille hectares de
forêts et broussailles ravagés dans les
provinces de kwanza et guadalajara en
plein centre de l'espagne
aidés par les bombardiers d'eau pompiers
et volontaires luttent pour éviter une
nouvelle propagation à quelques
kilomètres se dresse une centrale
nucléaire
l'intensité sondés diminué au cours des
dernières heures
la vague de chaleur qui frappe le centre
de l'espagne favorise incendie au
portugal devant la violence et la durée
du sinistre déjà 40 mille hectares
détruit cinq avions marocains et deux
canadair italiens sont venus en renfort
c'est là aussi la région centre qui est
la plus violemment touchés depuis une
semaine
la situation s'était encore aggravée la
nuit dernière
1200 pompiers et 400 militaires restent
mobilisés pour cet incendie sans
précédent image de contraste à l'île de
la réunion c'est la neige qui recouvrait
les sommets de l'île
un phénomène plutôt rare même si
actuellement c'est l'hiver là-bas reste
l'effet de surprise les réunionnais n'en
viennent pas de gros embouteillages se
sont formés pour admirer la neige j'ai
roulé sous de verglas la neige qui a
fait son apparition sans que la météo
n'en fassent la moindre prévision
repartons pour le massif des maures
saccagé par les incendies l'arrivée des
vacanciers s'est fait sans encombre des
regards de surprises parfaite
consternation pour les nouveaux
arrivants mais vite oublier yannick
aroussi besoin chante un air de services
de vidauban sur l'autoroute a8 les
incendies sont partis tout près d'ici et
c'est de là que la plupart des touristes
prennent contact avec le désastre
c'est vrai que là ça sent quand chaud
non
c'est très triste fait mal pour les gens
ici ça fait mal pour la région ça fait
j'espère que c'est pas les incendies
volontaires et pourtant ils n'ont encore
pas vu grand-chose famille juste le
temps de se rafraîchir et voici en route
vers plan de la tour et sainte-maxime
l'étendue de la catastrophe des arbres
calcinés le noir partout et des dizaines
des centaines de voitures car les
touristes qui sont bel et bien arrivés
malgré tout en arrivant si c'était
vraiment un paysage mortuaire quoi
vraiment vraiment impressionnant puis
parfois il ya l'odeur qui restent avant
de partir de marseille on a décidé de
téléphoner de demander un peu l'état des
dégâts les ampleurs et et sur le camping
aussi évident donc si le camping avait
eu des problèmes ont changé ça c'est sûr
on aura annulé ce camping de sainte
maxime intacte affiche presque complet
les vacanciers n'auront pas droit aux
promenades en forêt mais il reste la mer
et la piscine
de quoi passer un bon séjour dans
l'ensemble de ceux qui avaient réservé
vous voyez c'est il avait raison selon
les offices de tourisme on compte moins
de 5 % d'annulations
bien évidemment les campings ravagé par
les flammes ont dû fermer et finalement
sur la route des vacances
seul le paysage a changé les premiers
bilans de la saison touristique à mois
de juillet plutôt médiocre la montagne
n'échappe pas à la règle dans le
beaufortain la baisse de fréquentation
par rapport à l'année dernière et 5%
mais les professionnels comptent sur le
mois d'août qui s'annonce sous de
meilleurs auspices virginie ficher
belgique là c'est vrai qu'avec ces
chaleurs c'est bien aussi de de marché
un petit peu allons donc c'est une
balade tranquille à deux découvertes
pour faire tranquillité des couvertures
ses atouts séduisent toujours l'été la
montagne possède ses inconditionnels
mais les saisons se suivent et les
habitudes elle évolue on fait des
périodes de course et leurs huit ou
quinze jours ont par deux fois on part
une fois l'été une peau l'hiver pour la
neige un morcellement qui explique
peut-être qu'en juillet globalement les
simon - attirer les vacanciers le coeur
du beaufortain n'échappe pas à la
tendance à la centrale de réservation
d'un rush beaufort on relève notamment
un léger tassement du taux de
remplissage pour le mois écoulé de
l'ordre de 4 à 5 % beaucoup plus de
courts séjours sur mois de juillet avec
des gens qui viennent plus en dernière
minute qui viennent trois quatre jours
de plus et tant de gens de passage même
constat chez les commerçants moins
présent les touristes semblent également
moins dépensiers s'ils avaient vraiment
très cool et
on avait eu des par exemple ceux qui
venaient prenez des menus du plus simple
au juste un clin juste une salle herrade
le contexte économique morose les
conflits sociaux juste avant l'été les
tentatives d'explication sont nombreuses
mais ne suffisent pas le mois de juillet
sans en effet le sel sinistrés
bon d'accord c'était une saison qui
démarrait très très tôt au mois de mai
au mois de juin avec les longs week-ends
mais c'est vrai que si les gens sont
partis en week-end en mai en juin
au niveau financier ils sont peut-être
refaire quelques réserves en repartira
vacances et repartiront plus tôt au mois
d'août voire septembre un décalage qui
se traduit par des taux de réservation
de 80 à 95 % pour le mois d'août y
compris sur la dernière quinzaine
d'ordinaire plus calme décidément les
vacanciers sont de moins en moins
prévisible après l'arrestation d'yvan
colonna et la reprise des attentats
quasi quotidiens en corse se tient ce
week-end le rendez-vous annuel des
nationalistes le ton est donné
globalement ils considèrent que le
gouvernement est responsable du regain
de tension sur l'île et après le non au
référendum
il envisage de reprendre l'initiative
pour dessiner l'avenir de la corse à
corte
reportage et anne frontier sylvain aubin
c'est le dernier tatouage à la mode le
portrait d' yvan colonna l'ex fugitif le
plus recherché de france
aujourd'hui en prison valley acheter le
t-shirt aussi je pense qu'il doit y être
307 en soutien à lui aux autres
prisonnières l'arrestation de l'assassin
présumé du préfet erignac il y à un mois
reste un sujet sensible à corte au coeur
des montagnes corses les nationalistes
vont essayer de tirer le bilan d'un été
très agité en quelques semaines tout
s'est bousculé non référendum
verdict du procès erignac aujourd'hui
c'est le temps de la réflexion pour
l'instant il n'y a absolument pas de
dialogue avec le gouvernement
l'impasse est effectivement est
aujourd'hui le mot
entre entre le gouvernement et la corse
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de dialogue
véritable entre les nationalistes et le
gouvernement il y en a encore moins
corte c'est aussi l'occasion d'échanger
avec des militants étrangers catalan
écossais vasque sarde toutes les
familles nationalistes se regroupent
pour former une sorte d'internationale
séparatistes l'amitié entre régions
comme mot d'ordre nous sommes venus par
solidarité avec le peuple corse nous
partageons les mêmes combats politiques
les mêmes idées nous avons un idéal
commun celui de la liberté pour nous
peuple comme champ de la diva trash dans
le bois à quelques mois des élections
régionales de mars 2004 les militants
nationalistes corses vont essayer de se
regrouper de prôner l'union mais ils
vont également essayé de reprendre
contact avec le gouvernement
alors qu'une partie de leur base a
choisi une autre voie celle de la
radicalisation en irak alors que son
distribuer des photos de saddam hussein
retouchées par ordinateur simulant le
visage que pourrait prendre l'ancien
dictateur dans sa fuite ses deux fils
sonde était enterré dans le caveau
familial près de tikrit tu frédéric
retard des prières pour les morts un
caveau familial dans le village qui a vu
naître saddam hussein
c'est ici qu'ont été enterré ses deux
fils oudaï et qoussaï mais aussi
mustapha son petit fils de 14 ans tous
tués
il y a deux semaines dans une opération
impressionnante à mossoul
une centaine de personnes tous des
proches de la famille sont venus se
recueillir
presqu'en même temps partout dans le
pays les irakiens découvrez l'air un peu
dubitatifs les nouveaux visages de
saddam hussein en tout cas ceux imaginés
sur ordinateur par les américains cinq
portraits possible du président déchu
est toujours introuvable
de leur côté les deux filles de l'ancien
président installé provisoirement
jordanie se montre étonnamment clémente
elle dont les marées ont été liquidées
par l'entourage de leur père ont reconnu
à la télévision qu'elle ne voulait pas
le mettre encore plus en difficulté sur
le terrain les américains semblent
resserré de plus en plus l'étau autour
de saddam près de 700 arrestations à
l'espace d'une semaine et notamment la
nuit dernière à tikrit 100 de cet homme
présenté comme un garde du corps du
rights
cependant la résistance frappe toujours
encore un soldat américain tué
aujourd'hui lors de l'attaqué d'un
convoi attentat suicide au caucase plus
de 40 morts près de 80 blessées dans
l'explosion d'un camion contre un
hôpital militaire amos doc la piste
tchétchène est privilégiée au liberia
secoué par de violents affrontements
entre forces rebelles et
gouvernementales le président charles
taylor vienne s'engageait quitté le
pouvoir le 11 août prochain sous la
pression des états unis
c'est normalement son vice président qui
lui succédera dès lundi des premiers
contingents de la force africaine de
paix seront déployés aux états unis où
commencent les vacances présidentielles
george bush après avoir fait son bilan
de santé s'est envolé aujourd'hui pour
le texas quant à jacques chirac il est
arrivé au québec pour prendre quelques
jours de repos en france c'est la fin
des soldes aujourd'hui apparaît dans
plusieurs régions le bilan est décevant
après l'euphorie des premiers jours les
ventes sont vite retombés emilie
langlade bernard que leur coup de balai
sur les soldes pour un tiers des
départements les promotions c'est fini
les retardataires ont traqué les bonnes
affaires jusqu'au dernier moment
j'en ressors qu'avec un boulot donc je
vais voir dans les autres et on verra
bien mais je pense que ça va être un
petit peu tard je pense qu'on peut
vraiment faire des bonnes affaires
encore
meilleure qu'au début des salles vont
mettre un coup de sang froid pour la
fédération de nadim ans le bilan est
satisfaisant
+ 3 % de chiffre d'affaires par rapport
à l'an dernier
avec une nouveauté les hommes sont
devenus adeptes des soldes les marques
de luxe ont
haut de gamme ont très bien fonctionné
au début et on s'aperçoit que de plus en
plus les clients ont tendance à faire du
repérage à venir au mois de juin
et c'est les hommes sont arrivés dès le
premier jour des soldes en sachant ce
qu'ils voulaient acheter
déception en revanche pour le secteur de
la femme en légère baisse
les clientes sont désormais plus
exigeantes jusqu'à maintenant considéré
que les soldes c'était un moment où on
achetait des articles pas cher et
c'était la notion prix qui était
primordial dans le comportement d'achat
des soldes or cette année la
consommatrice attendait non seulement
des réductions de prix mais en plus des
articles à la mode ce qui est assez
paradoxal fort des soldes
autre difficulté certaines villes comme
paris sont à la traîne
la capitale a fait beaucoup moins bien
que la province les professionnels
demandent donc une date unique de
démarrage comme pour les soldes d'hiver
car dans certaines régions les
consommateurs profitent encore des
salles de d'été jusqu'au 12 août
prochain
les françaises sont de gros
consommateurs de chocolat 6 kg en mai
par personne chaque année c'est dire
l'importance de l'entrée en vigueur de
la directive européenne qui autorise
l'adjonction de matières grasses
végétales autres que le beurre de cacao
dans le chocolat laetitia faut que j'en
ai flanc jusqu'à présent la recette du
chocolat était assez simple partout
comme dans cette entreprise familiale on
utilisait des fèves de cacao du beurre
de cacao et du sucre mais désormais
l'europe autorise l'introduction de six
matières grasses végétales comme le
karité à un taux de 5% au nom de la
qualité les artisans français s'y sont
opposés près de 30 ans les tablettes
vont pouvoir continuer sable et
tablettes de chocolat
mais là où les artisans ont réussi
combat à gagner ce combat c'est de
pouvoir imposer le devoir d'information
le devoir de mentionner sur les
tablettes intégrant des matières grasses
végétales et des matières de substitut
au premier rang des produits concernés
la confiserie et les barres chocolatées
sur lesquelles le fabricant devra
signaler andra s'ils contiennent des
matières grasses végétales en plus du
beurre de cacao un devoir d'information
peut être embarrassant pour les
industries
tous se bâtit hier pour cette
autorisation aujourd'hui indique très
discrètement qu'ils n'utiliseront pas
ces graisses végétales
pourtant beaucoup moins chère que le
beurre de cacao dans cette usine on
fabrique du chocolat pour la plupart des
industriels est ici on s'adaptera aux
désirs du consommateur
notre métier c'est de fabriquer la
recette que de membres et clients et
donc si nous le demande je le ferais
signer ne manquent pas nous n'avons pas
le pouvoir est donc entre les doigts du
consommateur plus grave plus lourd sur
l'estomac est pour l'instant sa
préférence va au pur beurre de cacao
après l'accident de jeudi à sigean dans
l'aude une voiture a fauché un groupe
d'enfants à la tombée de la nuit faisant
huit blessés
nous avons voulu nous intéresser aux
règles de sécurité mises en place dans
les colonies de vacances sont-elles
respectées
tentative de réponse avec david bizier
et sébastien angles at on va vous
remettre un brassard pour l'ascension de
cet après midi donc c'est les animateurs
qui vont voulait distribuer vous les
mettez à vos bras et faut bien attacher
les d'accord même pour aller à la
piscine la petite colonie de vacances
d'andernos prend des allures de convois
exceptionnels
il s'agit juste de traverser la route et
de parcourir quelques centaines de
mètres mais pour la législation un
groupe c'est bel et bien un convoi qui
doit se signaler
de jour comme de nuit on applique le
code de la route et donc à l'évêque
qu'il occupe acier considéré comme un
convoi
et donc on met des passages de sécurité
comme ça qu il faut prendre et les
pistes cydia pour remonter au mans de
l'océan patrice barras le directeur est
maintenant en réunion avec son supérieur
hiérarchique
car chaque projet de sortie des enfants
doit recevoir l'accord de la direction
des centres de vacances de dl le sud à
l'heure hiérarchique a déjà refusé deux
activités cet été ce que je demande au
directeur et conseiller auditeur de
repérer le trajet et qui m'a envoyé un
plan de prévention
une fois le plan de prévention reçu
j'examine là on donne deux moniteurs à
l'avant deux moniteurs à l'arrière le
convoi arrive à la piscine
anthony obert lui ne se baigne jamais
car là aussi la sécurité absorbe
beaucoup du temps des appuis difficiles
c'est moins trois minutes pour une
noyade
c'est vrai que c'est assez difficile à
est assez contraignant tous les jours
d'être à bord de sa piscine et on n'a
pas le choix
trop bien le faire parce que sont hélas
pour eux
cyclisme laurent gagnier a remporté la
médaille d'or de vitesse individuelle
aux championnats du monde de stuttgart
c'est le deuxième titre remporté par le
français au cours de ces championnats
gilles un bon moment décidément
l'allemagne souri à l'organique
deux jours après sa victoire en terrine
quatre ans après avoir décroché l'or à
berlin laurent gané héros devenu
champion du monde de vitesse
individuelle
le titre le plus prestigieux de la
compétition à stuttgart le
néo-calédonien s'est imposé deux manches
à une face à l'australien dash qu'à un
brin tendu signe que laurent gané est
revenu au plus haut niveau lui qui avait
connu des ennuis de santé
c'est un peu au goût de revanche parce
que c'est vrai que ces trois dernières
années j'ai manqué un peu de chance
cette année bassin solide
avant de la marseillaise ça représente
quelque chose pour toi ça représente
quoi ouais c'est sait se montrer que
l'équipe de france n'est pas encore
mentionné qu'elle est bel et bien là et
je compte énormément dans un présent
pour le jeu et c'est vrai que l'équipe
de france va mieux
la preuve avec cette autre succès cette
fois en course par équipes sur quatre
kilomètres
médaille de bronze pour les français de
bonne augure pour les jeux olympiques
d'athènes
tu seras dont un peu plus d'un an
football première journée du championnat
de l1 en match avancé monaco a battu
bordeaux stade louis ii 2 à 0 grâce à un
doublé de shabani nonda meilleur buteur
de la saison 2002-2003 avec 26
réalisations
une victoire méritée pour les
monégasques qui ont dominé le match
son succès ne se dément pas chacun de
ces ouvrages est un best-seller
phénomène de l'édition mondiale mary
higgins clark auteur prolifique de
romans policiers à succès caracole en
tête des ventes nos correspondants
pascal golomer et tristan le braz le
rencontrer chez elle dans le new-jersey
c'est sa maison du bord de mer à une
heure du matin et en bonne maîtresse des
lieux
mary higgins clark ne se lasse jamais de
raconter par le menu les travaux qu'elle
a dû consentir pour la rénover cette
maison et lévis dès que les beaux jours
arrivent
elle y écrit aussi tous les matins comme
d'autres irait jouer au tennis dit elle
quand je réfléchis à quelque chose quand
je me relis j'aime me tenir comme cela
avec la mer en face c'est la ruée
l'odeur de la mer ainsi c'est quelque
chose de très important pour moi
elle y écrit des histoires d'amour et de
suspense ou les bons triomphe toujours
des méchants des histoires qui se
vendent à des dizaines de millions
d'exemplaires avant d'être projeté à
l'écran
bignone qu'est ce qu'il ya
un immense succès et cela fait plus de
25 ans que ça dure mais sort et l écrire
autre chose puisque les critiques ont
été parfois si dur avec moi j'aimerais
écrire une oeuvre plus littéraire la
plus convoitée j'en suis capable mais je
le ferai sous un nom d'emprunt pour
l'instant c'est son autobiographie
qu'elle prépare la vie d'une hôtesse de
l'air qui prit la plume d'abord par goût
puis pour nourrir ses enfants elle qui
lui attendre six ans et 40 refus avant
de publier sa première nouvelle savoure
aujourd'hui son succès de conteur jamais
à court d'anecdotes semble juste
derrière vous j'ai étranglée quelques
uns quand son ami la découvrit s'exclame
oh mon amour qui a bien pu faire une
horreur pareille et cela s'est passé
juste sur ce belvédère
alors si vous vous promenez sur la côte
est des états unis
prenez garde aux décors et aux
personnages mary higgins clark n'est
peut-être pas très loin que les
intermittents refont parler d'eux ils
étaient près de 2 semble que cet
après-midi de l'accès la pyramide du
louvre ils se sont dispersés après avoir
bloqué pendant deux heures l'entrée
principale du musée
le festival interceltique de lorient
s'est ouvert hier sans encombre après
l'accord signé entre la direction et des
intermittents du spectacle six mille six
cent mille spectateurs et 4500 musiciens
sont attendus à cette manifestation qui
a son hymne et son offre comme à avignon
charles est mouillé carrure et qu ils
ont sorti leur plus bel instrument leurs
plus beaux costumes l'alignement est
parfait normal ces artistes concours
pour le très sérieux
championnats du monde de bagadoù dans le
stade de lorient ça c'est pour le in du
festival et puis il ya les off dans les
rues de la ville chaleur et beau temps
on aurait pu croire tout le monde à la
plage mais non certains préfèrent la
guitare au bruit des vagues
c'est un commencement la musique est
belle sur la plage plus de garder sinon
et si pour l'instant la ville est au
ralenti certains se préparent une soirée
puristes qui place qui vante qui est du
monde pas le monde de l'entreprise
sauf que dans la rue
et ça tombe bien aujourd'hui les
artistes sont aussi dans la rue et pas
pour manifester pour jouer une fierté
pour l'organisation du festival et nous
avons trouvé un modus vivendi avec les
intermittents parce que nous avons des
choses en commun que des intermittents
nous sommes d'accord sur le fond pas
toujours sur la forme
donc les intermittents pourront
s'exprimer exprimé avant les concerts
lors de forums
quand il rencontre la presse vient effet
qu'il ya toujours une possibilité de
même fait agréable bah je ne sais pas
pour l'instant il ya
hier j'ai joué je n'ai pas fait grève
donc ce soir il y aura une discussion
avec des musiciens il ce sera comme ça à
chaque fois mais pour ceux qui ont
choisi la scène aujourd'hui
pas de nuage à l'horizon public content
tant de rêves
le festival prend son rythme de
croisière se termine ce journal dans un
instant météo noté lee rihouet 20h55
fort boyard une heure le dernier journal
présenté par alexandre kara quant à moi
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain dès 13 heures je vous remercie de
votre attention
bonne soirée sur france 2 ans quitte
avec ses images de sculptures de sable
sur les plages de zeebrugge en belgique
9000 tonnes de sable ont été nécessaires
pour réaliser sur le monument c'est mr